this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia.edu I am absolutely delighted
to be able to introduce actually
lightning as one of our featured
speakers once again I ask that you look
at your program and read her
biographical sketch she's recently
admitted into the doctoral program and
also is denominated to receive a
fellowship because she just that
outstanding addition after she speaks
for me to have lisa matthews talk about
her experiences in jamaica and then
we're going to have Sharon Stan's blog
about her experiences in Kenya and then
Amrita will talk about her experiences
in India and I will do my best we made
time to represent should we capture her
project and hate all this as a part of a
larger Provost funded project called a
building local and global hiv/aids
prevention capacity something like that
without further ado Ashley bitin thank
you so I tried to include a lot of
visuals and videos as I know after lunch
it's difficult to stay awake and
everything so I'm going to be talking
about my project capacity building in
Togo so when I was awarded the
fellowship with the research group of
asperities and help dr. Wallace asked me
where can you see yourself adopting and
implementing this training and as it
turns out a friend of mine
was in the Peace Corps in a small
village in the north of Togo and she had
recently opened up in HIV AIDS clinic
but for reasons a sigma it was difficult
to get people to the clinic and she was
telling me that they needed some sort of
educational program so it was just too
serendipitous not to do it and then I
set off on this journey to implement
this training in Togo so the first step
was doing pre-training one-on-one
interviews with Togolese immigrants in
the New York area and from these
interviews I found out a lot of really
interesting cultural insights they told
me a lot about that I would encounter
stigma depending on who I was speaking
to some of the older people said to me
that I should never say the word sex or
homosexuality other people felt
differently they informed me about some
cultural practices that could you know
facilitate the transmission of HIV aids
such as ritual scarring sharing blades
cutting umbilical cord often with
breaking a bottle even to use that glass
and telling me that if a man dies his
brother can marry his wife they also
talked about dry sex which is the
practice of intravaginal insertion of
drying agents and how with the economy
men can afford to have as many wives so
each wife is now having more babies and
so the drug that's why this in this
insertion would make them more desirable
and they also let me know that the
people in togo would be very receptive
if I included a lot of stories and
sketches or skits to show them how good
behavior could lead to a good future and
also in terms of scheduling I was going
there during farming season so that was
important to consider when deciding when
to hold the training on which days
okay so just to give you a little idea
of where exactly Togo is it's in West
Africa and I was in the village in the
north called k tau which is in the
curragh region so I was very close to
the border with been in we actually
walked to the market and been in several
times Cara is actually the third largest
city in Togo too so this is really
interesting because Kate I was a very
rural village but it was only 20
kilometers from one of the largest
cities so it's kind of a crossroads
between rural and urban and the
situation in Togo has a population of
six and a half million people the life
expectancy at Birth for men is 55 for
women 60 the probability of dying under
five per 1,000 live births is 107 the
total expenditure on health is percent
of gross domestic product is
five-and-a-half percent and then
something that was really really really
exciting for me to learn because when i
was there in august of 2008 the
government didn't have any programs to
give out free antiretrovirals there was
a rupture and the stock and even some of
the people with you know the highest
economic status could not obtain these
medications so as in November 2008 they
started distributing some free
antiretrovirals to people that were
currently on them as well as 4,000 new
people however this is happening more in
loma in the capital city which in the
south so we're not really sure yet how
is this going to affect the village of
Cape Town and in January 2009 the Global
Fund fight AIDS tuberculosis and malaria
announced 94 million dollar plan
over the next five years so 25 million
dollars of this is going to go to
stopping antiretrovirals the estimated
adult of HIV prevalence here is about
four percent but like i said it's likely
much higher because these statistics
come mainly from a few clinics in lomé a
in the capital and so the village I
wasn't for example a few people there
had ever even done HIV test and you can
see that it's kind of plateauing the
annual number of aids deaths per year is
about 150,000 and this I thought was
really interesting that these
behavioural trends and so the first
graph here the first charge shows you
the percentage of women in med aged 15
to 49 who had sexual intercourse with
more than one partner in the last 12
months and you see men there at about
twenty two percent and women at about
three percent and then in the next chart
we see what percent of these people used
condoms during the last sexual encounter
and you actually see that men answered
that they've been using condoms about
third about thirty-five percent of men
whose these condoms whereas only closer
to twenty percent of woman okay so um
the training manual that I adapted to
implement my training was dr. Wallace's
manual combining hiv/aids peer education
and combining African healing wisdom and
evidence-based behavior strategies so
each one can teach one to be safe from
hiv/aids and the manual include was
based on three theories for behavior
change motivational interviewing that we
learned a lot about this morning as well
as stages of change and relapse
prevention so now I'm going to take you
along this journey with me traveling to
the festival grounds because
that's really the metaphor for this
training and in order to arrive safely
at the festival grounds which is you
know a stage of safety it was really
important to use a body system and to
look for our peers to offer social
support so here I'm arriving in the
village of K tau and this was the road
that I took every morning from the house
that I was staying in to the school we
did the training and in adapting to my
new environment I really relied on some
of the things I learned during my
one-on-one pre-training interviews for
example that I should always only use my
right hand when shaking someone's hand
or you know when doing any kind of
interaction along with other traditions
and stuff so then within the first three
days of being there I actually we had a
meeting at AED which is the clinic that
my friend a media who say the Peace
Corps volunteer their help to open and
we met with a few people that she had
selected as potential trainers and we
talked about the application process you
know who are our participants going to
be and I came with these with these
application forms and y'all was really
excited maybe we'll do a radio show or
maybe we'll post them in the market or
pass them out and we'll see who wants to
attend this training but i was told
actually that this was discrimination
because so many people were going to
want to attend this training that how
could I tell people this opportunity
exists but you can't take it so I was
really really grateful to have the
insight of these community members
because what they suggested was that we
shouldn't ask the chief of the village
to talk with the chief Cartier's which
are the Chiefs of each section of the
village and the beach chief Cartier
should
should select one female and one male
member and that the director of the high
school and high school students their
range for about 18 to 26 years old that
the director of the high school should
then also select ten females and ten
nails so we had a lot of meetings a lot
of you know door to door and home visits
and everything and within you know three
days the chief organized a large meeting
they had selected the participants and
we were told that they were going to
arrive Monday for our training later on
I think we would learn that doing it
this way involving the entire community
really contributed to the zero-percent
attrition rate and the overall just one
hundred percent dedication of the peer
educators I think we had to absentee hes
on 2 given days and that person's one of
their siblings came to the place I was
staying came to the house of the
trainers to explain to us why their
sibling would not be attending that day
so this was really really exciting and
who were the participants just to give
you a little idea there were 20 female
and 23 male participants the mean age
was 23 years old with a range from 18 to
49 seventy-eight percent of the
population were not married twenty-three
percent were married forty percent of
the participants completed middle school
thirty-three percent completed high
school and twenty-seven percent were
still in high school the participants
occupations ranged from being students
to community health workers to taxi
drivers to cleaning ladies to merchants
come to woodworkers and teachers so it
really was a very diverse population and
twenty percent of participants had
participated in a previous hiv/aids
training in terms of access ninety
percent of the participants had access
to radio thirty percent had accessed
television but this doesn't
they had a television at home there were
a few televisions in the village where
you could pay to go watch a soccer game
or to watch a TV show fifteen percent of
the participants either had access to
the internet or we're trying to open up
an internet account so as I said there
was actually no internet in the village
of K tau but it was only 20 kilometres
from the city of Korra and now they have
internet cafes where people could go and
use the internet and while ninety-eight
percent of participants reported having
access to condoms all but one
participant said that they had to pay
for these condoms um before I show you
this short video I wanted to talk a
little bit about in the first week of
the training we did some team-building
activities just to make sure that the
participants really were going to work
well with their fellow peers since it
was a new group appears it wasn't you
know just classmates or warrant wasn't
just you know all people that worked in
the same trade and so we every day for
the first two weeks did a few
team-building activities
wait no okay um and then also I want to
share with you in the manual there was a
set of affirmations and they adapted
these affirmations and said them every
morning and created songs with these
affirmations and it was a really
wonderful way to ensure that everyone
arrived on time so we put in half an
hour of padding in the morning and they
would do breathing exercises and
affirmations and so this is a set of
affirmations of one of the groups
so I think establishing these you can't
analyze reckon I think establishing
these affirmations during the first few
days really gave him a chance to sit
there with their buddies and with their
peers and to say to themselves ok this
is a set of affirmations you know that
was in the manual what can we add to
this what does this mean to us how is
this going to guide the process of us
learning to be peer educators learning
to be the best you know trainers we can
be the best family members community
educators and so that was really
exciting they love them to like you hear
them seeing them all around the village
and it was always in my head for the two
months that I was living there and
they're really beautiful so during weeks
two and three we focused a lot on the
knowledge portion and this range from
teaching about prevention and
transmission to teaching about nutrition
to medical adherence cultural practices
and then of course there was a lesson in
the manual on supportive optimistic and
positive peers so it was soft but they
changed it to pops because of this peer
hope Denise was a teeth and see fatigue
so they actually changed the supportive
too sympathetic because they thought
that was really important and like the
acronym in pops so they'd walk around
and ask people if they were pops and
later on you'll see some of the
sketchings they sign things pops all the
time just kind of as a reminder of this
you know the importance of social
support so to show you some of how some
of the learning took place and the way
that they exhibited the learning I'll
show you a few just visuals of some of
the sketches they did and explain
situations that they brainstorm
in relationship to the knowledge that
they were learning so this sketch took
place sorry I'm saying sketch because
it's a skit or a role play but they call
their sketches this I think I thought
into that habit but this was during the
knowledge portion on prevention and
transmission and one thing that they
focused on a lot the peer educators was
fidelity so in being faithful so in this
sketch you have one of the peer
educators and he has a few different
girlfriends and he's you know sleeping
around with them and there's one scene
where his mom finds condoms and this
actually commented 2 and a lot of these
you know inter generational differences
and my mom is upset with him what are
you doing with these condoms there will
be no condoms in my home like my son is
not having sex and so you see that he's
having to kind of you know sneak around
this and as it turns out he finds out
he's infected and he sees that he's
infected multiple partners and so it
just really brought awareness to these
issues and you know the complexity and
importance of prevention and you know
how to teach their fellow community
members you know proper prevention
techniques and to talk about condom use
here's a skit about social support and
here you have a guy that found out that
he's HIV positive and he's saying I want
to kill myself I'm going to die and you
have the pops the supportive optimistic
sympathetic and positive peers who are
explaining them with their new knowledge
is peer educators you don't have to feel
this way you don't have to think this
way no one is going to alienate you
they're going to be people that are
going to support you they explained to
him what was going on what his options
were they walked him over to ad the
clinic and the village
or he could get some counseling services
and then they helped him you know talk
about how to explain this to his family
to his friends and there was one part of
this skit where when he told people that
he was infected everyone started running
away and they would you know leave the
food and in the middle of the field and
make him run out to get it and so they
exemplify no we can eat with these
people that are infected you know we can
hug people that infected and so just way
that they thought the community would
really relate to learning about this and
this is one of the role plays on
cultural practices and for a lot of the
people in the village the whole idea of
female genital cutting or female
circumcision female genital mutilation
was really important because it's
something that a lot of them believe
should not happen anymore however it's a
tradition and they were saying you know
how can we stand up to our elders and
two people that have been practicing
this for so many generations and say no
and one of the concerns was that often
the same blade is reused on many
different people sometimes there's even
a ritual ceremony where there's dances
going on and you can select the person
that you want to cut you and so while
there are many mixed feelings about this
what they all agreed on is that there
needs to be dialogue about it so in this
specific skin you have a woman who is
telling her husband our daughter is not
going to get cut and so she is having an
argument with her husband and she's
supporting her daughter because the
daughter saying like daddy I don't want
do this things are changing I shouldn't
have to do this it's not safe and the
mother is supporting her and you
actually it's really interesting as you
see this woman taking this just this
really powerful role and saying this
isn't even going to be a discussion we
have decided this is not best for my
child's health so this brought up a lot
of really interesting issues and lastly
in this get here the women are talking
about the practice of passing a widowed
woman on to her deceased husband's
brother because often if people are
dying of HIV AIDS well if you're going
to pass if you're going to pass the
woman that's left behind on to you know
someone else's husband and it goes both
ways then people are just reinfecting
people and in this case this woman had
got infected that way and so she's
talking about it with her friends and
her friends are saying we don't want
this to happen to us and you know we
should have the right to choose who we
marry and so this also brought up a lot
of these issues um so now I'm going to
talk about some of the training
activities that we did in order to learn
about the different levels of risk for
HIV transmission we played this game
called the traffic light of love and um
so I started to mention this before but
during the training there were three
groups each of the three trainers had
their own group and sometimes for the
larger lectures they come together and
learn together and they would also
present their skits and their songs to
each other so I thought that this
activity was really interesting because
what we did is we distributed a bunch of
strips with
for in sexual acts on them and the
participants the peer educators had to
decide what risk level they fell under
so if something was not at all risky you
want a super cool okay sure no it did to
pay i can use this so if something
wasn't risky than it was green light go
ahead if there was some way some caution
involved i was yellow and then read was
you know very high risk and when I
looked at the three posters that the
groups had created I found something in
common in all of them kissing was always
either caution yellow or sometimes even
high risk it red because you know there
could be a cut in the mouth and you know
blood or you know semen in her vaginal
secretions could enter that way but
vaginal sex with the condom was always
green at the green light go ahead so
when I asked the participants if they
knew about the fact that condoms aren't
always one hundred percent effective
because sometimes they can break they
said of course we know that and so I
said to them well then that's a direct
port of entry why would you know sex
without with a condom be a green light
and they said to me I don't understand
we are pure educators and we are telling
people how to stay safe so if we tell
them that using condoms has some
cautionary risks how are they going to
listen to us and I realized that they
knew best how to talk to their peers how
to talk to their community and this was
something that I had to accept that this
was just a cultural difference and that
it made sense that they thought like
this and then this was a time to save
them okay well in talking about
prevention you know we're tell them to
use condoms but also you know we should
talk about you know the risks
Congress breaking and things like that
but I thought that was really
interesting because there were many
times where I had to really set back and
realized that I come from you know a
different set of cultural beliefs and
I'm not always going to be writing
things aren't can always what I say
isn't can always make sense to them and
in no way should I expect that they will
accept all the information and knowledge
and I'm passing it to them but also you
know there's so much that I can learn
from them and then these issues really
are complex in every community in every
place in the world is going to think
about them differently another example
of the game we played was survivor
island when they took on fictional roles
of power from being a multi-millionaire
to a community outreach leader and the
rest of participants acted as a jury and
I decide whose life was the most
important life to stay there was a
sinking lifeboat and one person could
live and this was interesting for me to
in a challenge and exploring new
paradigms of learning because the
learning style and most of their
schooling and Togo has been dictation
centered and here I'm telling them to
question people that might be the
President or someone that might be a
multi-billionaire and it was just really
interesting to explore these new roles
also as we'll talk about a little bit
later with global help which we want to
invite all of you to engage in and
participate on we there's something
really wonderful about sharing tools
across different trainings and this is a
chutes and ladders board the de peer
educator is created with some high-risk
situations unsafe situations and this is
the best practice that was created in m
ritter
as much of a house experience with
prisoners in India and so we kind of
readapted this and now this board is
used by many of the pure education peer
educators and some of the projects that
they're doing in schools and other
community events and during week four we
taught the stages of safety and this is
a part of the manual and it's really
about avoiding lapses and relapses to
unsafe behaviors while emphasizing how
to cope in these high-risk situations so
there were some other dances that they
created and symbols to discuss the six
steps to the stages of safety because it
was easier to remember it that way so in
the counseling that they would later on
do and their roles as peer educators it
was something that they used and as I
said they created many songs during the
training so here's another one that I
wanted to share with you and it's really
interesting because these songs are
really educational tools because they're
things that can be presented at
community forums at schools and it was
just really a great way to relay
information
okay so we had a lot of fun during the
training and it was wonderful but they
also learned a lot they really really
did and this you could see not only in
the skits in the role plays and the
diversity of the questions they came
with the experiences they shared the
knowledge that they had but also we
administered a 30 item questionnaire
that's part of the manual that was
administered at pre-tests and post-tests
and their scores from baseline to post
test showed that showed that they were
significant about the level of point
zero zero zero so on average they had
learned you know five new concepts it
really improved on and there was no
difference in knowledge between the
female and the male participants and
iPhone is really interesting the only
group that was significantly different
in terms of their knowledge from all the
other groups was the group that was
still in high school so the group that
was still in high school performed far
better than the group that had completed
high school and this might point to the
fact that there's more HIV AIDS
education going on in school because the
30 item test was a test of hiv/aids
knowledge and on the self-rating
evaluation at the end all of the peers
it was showed a significant increase in
their ability to teach many of these
techniques that they learned and in
order to move their peers across the
stages of change and to teach positive
attitudes so when the training was done
we have a big final ceremony and they
like to call
these sensible is a shins because they
it's a way to sensible Isaac community
and we have the final ceremony come in
the middle of the market which was
really exciting it was on a saturday
morning in the middle of the market of
really busy place it's you know
everyone's coming through here and we
had about 400 people attend and there
were chairs for the hundred notables for
the people that the mayors and the
Chiefs from surrounding villages it came
and then you had just people walking by
stopping by to watch the skits so just
to give you an idea the energy that was
there that day
so the first person he thought I was the
chief of the village and the second
woman was taught to use the president of
the ad clinic and also one of our
trainers so just to talk a little bit
about what's going on now I left the
training ended what's going on right now
in K tau so the peer educators elected a
bureau and a president they still
actually hold weekly meetings and they
developed a few proposal ideas and with
the help of my friend media who say
who's there they were able to get a us a
grant to initiate three projects one to
create a Moringa garden I'm an anti-aids
club in my high schools which includes a
film screening series murals are dancing
and three large sensitization and radio
shows they've also rented out bars to do
trainings for different for hairdressers
wood makers tailors and other
apprentices dosa the President does
counseling sessions in the new office
and saw a smile there and they plan to
start a music group with young kids and
possibly sell condoms as a way to
finance and pay the rent for the office
space that they just rented and to make
this really sustainable and this is
actually a picture of the Moringa garden
that they planted back in november and
Moringa is a plant that has a lot of
nutritional benefits to strengthen the
immune system so a lot of people that
don't have access to a rv's of losing
that's a problem they'll take marengo to
help strengthen their immune system and
so this is in late November but I was
just informed that they actually now
have 100 trees and they're going to
plant 100 more trees and they have
enough right now to use to actually
start selling for food so in addition
it's an ink
generating activity that can also help
contribute to the sustainability of the
project and this is um dosa the
president this is one of the film
screenings that he's doing and they use
these films called scenarios in Africa
that were made by community members time
demonstrating different prevention and
other information and so this is in
school and they also created several
billboards that are now all around k'tau
all around the village the secular this
one you see use a condom roll leave you
this one let's take the test to live a
better future so they're referring to
the HIV test and this one to avoid aids
we must abstain from sex before marriage
and be faithful once were married so
that's and my presentation and I really
really just want to thank dr. Barbara
Wallace for granting me this opportunity
to go to tell Bo and to work with her
manual and adapted and the research
group of disparities in health also
immediately say the Peace Corps
volunteer in the village of K towel that
you know helped all these arrangements
I'm rinse eval who shared with me so
many best practices from her experience
in India and just offering me a lot of
support palapa coupon rule who is a
friend of mine in New York who served as
a key informant and then of course the
peer educators so on a last note I want
to leave you with this is another bill
when it created those living with AIDS
will always be our friends and brothers
okay yes mm-hmm okay dry sex is the
practice of inserting drying agents into
the vagina so this can mean herbs or
detergents and the reason that woman
would do this would be to preserve the
vaginal structure and to make it smaller
because this would be more desirable to
men and would represent that she was
being faithful thank you thank you for
your excellent presentation and to
barber for supporting us and developing
it it was really spectacular so my
question is where else has this program
in this way we've been implemented
number one and number two I personally
see through contact some of the
opportunities where this is an advocate
can be and so what are the possibilities
of that well the great thing is is that
the next few presentations that are
going to follow me are going to show
what they're doing to implement this in
other countries so the very first
training was done in Sierra Leone in
2005 by dr. Richard Kandra and he
actually was first one to pilot the
manual
was in July of 2005 and then not a
crunch my walk folk did a four week
intensive training in latte ghana in
january of 2006 and so we certainly
welcome opportunities to replicate they
train I also know actually it was a net
Johnson I think who told me that I was
in a hall bini and I stopped by this
church and they were having a session
based on your manual so the idea is for
it to be available the public domain
global health base is available on the
Internet so it's a downloadable document
for free dissemination but we were both
on now from okay yeah well we didn't
work directly with the government we
worked with people in the community and
really once we spoke with the community
chief he suggested that we use the space
of the elementary school so it was a lot
of houses its involved and just asking
the involvement we went to talk to the
director of the
elementary school he was really excited
about the training and he let us use
that space actually yeah people were
very supportive our project the
preceding program was brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu